the following content is provided under  a Creative Commons license your support  will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to  offer high quality educational resources  for free  to make a donation or view additional  materials from hundreds of MIT courses  visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu  so let's see if you can figure out this  next error oh nice  looks like a hundred percent are getting  it right so far so we have L is equal to  three for I in range length L print I  and this is the error message I get  telling me the file the line and the  actual line blind number in the actual  line that's wrong and then a description  of the error type error okay and  everyone's getting it right which is  what's the problem here we're not  allowed to call length on an integer  okay if you go through the other the  other choices you'll see that those you  can actually do and you can even test  those out yourself before you settle on  on the right answer